all right we're gonna play marry
kill Jeff Sessions Sean Spicer and Steve
Bannon Jesus Christ I only get a
merit one marry one kill one ray all of
them if I'm involved or bad they're all
punishment okay marrying me is way worse
than dying for me they'll just be a
you can always the one you killed
first I would get a horribly sexually
transmitted disease and then I would
Sean Spice what I do is I actually
make a human centipede first and I feel
like Spicer has to be talking at the
front right right it's got to be the
face concessions in the middle just
gonna poop no good point
I feel like Bannon hasn't been working
out here's the great thing about these
three me putting them in a human
centipede I could catch any one of them
that's true I'm spry I go to yoga and
stuff once I've made them a new human
centipede they're basically my bride
they're going to die that's true I'm not
gonna keep a human centipede around or
not it that's real like what do
what do we do half the point what what
is this you and if you're doing it's to
look at